There aren't many heroes in The Devil All
the Time, but if you look hard, you'll find
at least one.
Young Arvin Russell, played by Tom Holland,
is everything that the other residents of
Coal Creek, West Virginia and Knockemstiff,
Ohio are not.
He's kind and brave, always ready to stick
up for others, and never backs down from a
fight.
In other words, he's the perfect character
for Holland to play.
Just look at Holland's first scene in the
movie.
Eight years after a tragic and bizarre set
of circumstances left Arvin an orphan and
forced him to move in with his grandmother
Emma, his great-uncle Erskell, and his stepsister
Lenora, Arvin celebrates his birthday.
On the surface, it's a sweet scene, but like
everything in The Devil All the Time, there's
much more lurking just under the surface.
Not only is this sequence full of grim portents
about the Russell family's future, but it's
the first time we see Arvin fully grown and
get a glimpse of the man he's become.
Holland's performance in this scene tells
the audience everything they need to know
about Arvin, plays on Holland's natural strengths,
and shows exactly why he's one of Hollywood's
go-to leading men.
Despite all the amoral, violent, and downright
evil characters that come and go throughout
The Devil All the Time, you can't help but
get the sense that Arvin is a character who's
deeply, inherently kind.
This scene proves it from the start.
Look at the party his family throws for him.
There's not much to the cake that Emma bakes.
It's lumpy and unfrosted.
It doesn't even have real birthday candles.
Arvin's sole present is a hand-me-down from
a father that Arvin had a complicated relationship
with, a relic of a brutal war, and a very
odd gift for a teenager.
But Arvin doesn't complain.
In fact, he welcomes all of it.
When he sees the cake, as modest as it is,
he smiles.
Before blowing out his lone candle, he gives
his wish real thought, proving that his traumatic
childhood hasn't robbed him of all his innocence.
Despite the baggage attached to the gun, he
seems genuinely thankful.
"It's the best present I ever got.
Thank you, Uncle Erskell."
And when Lenora leans in for a hug, Arvin
welcomes it, marking a stark contrast to 9-year-old
Arvin's passive embrace of Emma in the scene
before.
Arvin's later actions go even further in proving
his genuine nature, but this scene sets the
stage.
All throughout The Devil All the Time after
this moment, you never have any doubt that
Arvin is a good person, no matter what he
does.
That's the power Holland brings to the character.
Young Arvin, played by Michael Banks Repeta,
is mostly reactive.
Things happen to him, but he doesn't drive
the action.
After the birthday party, that changes.
Lenora is sweet but naive, and Emma and Erskell
aren't getting any younger.
When Arvin blows out that candle, he effectively
becomes the man of the house.
His family is now under his protection, and
he makes good on that dynamic as the film
progresses.
"I know you'd probably rather be doing something
else.
We're kin, and all we got for each other."
He knows it, too.
Note the studied, respectful glance he gives
his father's gun when he receives it.
This isn't a child who's ignoring the responsibilities
he's been given.
This is a young man who's just been given
the power to kill, and he's going to use it
wisely.
This plays out as the film continues.
It's Arvin who protects Lenora from bullies.
It's Arvin who consoles Emma when Reverend
Teagardin humiliates her.
And when things get really bad, it's Arvin
who sacrifices his happiness for the sake
of his loved ones.
"'Scuse me, preacher.
You got time for a sinner?"
Many of Arvin's actions later in The Devil
All the Time are shocking, but they're all
set up by this early birthday scene.
Really, you should've seen 'em all coming.
All that being said, Arvin Russell isn't like
any character that Holland has played before.
When he's on screen, Holland is often very
high energy, and he's usually quite chatty.
"Well I could have stuck the landing a little
better.
It's just, new suit, well — it's nothing.
Mr. Stark, it's, it's perfect, thank you.”
“Yeah we don't really need to start a conversation.”
“Okay.
Cap..Captain."
But unlike so many of Holland's memorable
characters, Arvin doesn't quip.
He doesn't banter.
In fact, much of the time, he doesn't say
anything at all.
"Ah, I might've put my foot in something.
Wasn't my intentions."
Again, look at the birthday party scene as
an example.
During the celebration, Holland only has a
few real lines.
And yet not only does he carry the scene,
but he's able to convey so much crucial information
about Arvin through his body language alone
that he really doesn't need to speak at all.
The Devil All the Time is significantly darker
than anything Holland has done before, and
it directly tackles mature themes that his
previous blockbusters only hinted at.
It's a challenging movie, and Arvin could
only have been played by a confident, experienced
actor.
Naturally, Holland nails it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Netflix movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.